[ Musique ]
Commentaire :
La 21ème édition du Challenge des Créateurs
a été lancée ce mardi 2 octobre au Village Corail.
Une matinée dédiée au speed casting où les 96
candidats ont à tour de rôle présenté
leur projet de création d'entreprise
devant le jury. Ils ont eu huit minutes chacun.
J'ai une entreprise artisanale
en fait de création de bijoux pour homme
et femme et mes matières premières sont
essentiellement le cuir et des après
argentés avec un plaquage argent 10 microns.
Alors ça pourrait m'aider par
exemple à pouvoir faire un salon
professionnel sur Paris, ça pourrait
m'aider aussi à développer ma notoriété
au niveau de l'île, développer encore
plus mon activité au niveau de la
renommée et surtout aussi beaucoup d'échanges avec d'autres entrepreneurs où
il y a énormément de richesse dans la
diversité des entrepreneurs qui étaient ici.
Donc j'ai présenté un petit pupitre
en tamarin, pliable, de création qui
s'appelle "pupitre Basilou" et qui est destiné
aux enfants de 2 à 9 ans et une taille
plus grande de 9 ans à adulte.
Ben gagner le prix ça serait bien ça donne un
petit coup de pouce à l'activité
artisanale qui est compliquée quand même
dans le bois massif.
Et puis du coup j'ai pris un atelier à
l'étang salé dans la zone des sables du
coup voilà j'aurai besoin d'acheter des
machines pour évoluer, progresser
et embaucher et faire grandir
l'activité Basilou.
Commentaire :
Des projets innovants et performants qui ont rendu
la tâche difficile au jury pour les départager.
Il y avait de beaux projets, 96 candidats
qui ont présenté des projets devant le jury
Bon les discussions ont été âpres
mais le jury a été unanime sur le nom
des 14 lauréats donc 14 lauréats
heureux et je dirais, ce sont les lauréats
mais les 96 candidats ont eu quand même
ce plaisir de pouvoir présenter leur
projet et ça servira peut-être pour
peaufiner certains points et présenter
d'autres projets dans l'avenir.
Commentaire : Le challenge des créateurs, un concours qui démontre que la création d'entreprise
peut être un outil d'insertion pérenne.
Alors ce que le concours va leur apporter
bien sûr pour les lauréats 7000 euros en numéraire
1500 euros pour les finalistes, des heures de conseil avec des experts comptables, des adhésions au
centre de gestion agréé, du coaching de
la cgss et surtout ce que ca va
ramener donc c'est une validation de leur
projet et une valorisation en terme
d'image au travers ce concours et les
moyens médias mis en place par le
Département et ses partenaires.
Commentaire : 14 finalistes pour 7 prix,
la décision finale sera donnée à l'issue d'un jury
institutionnel au mois de novembre
au sein du Conseil Départemental.
[ musique ]